DEPUTIES ACTED DURING THE
SHOOTING?
WE HAVE SO MUCH BREAKING NEWS IN
OUR OPENING MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT, MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT IN THE FISA ABUSE
SCANDAL.
WE'LL START THERE.
WE ARE GETTING ONE STEP CLOSER
TO HOLDING TOP LEVEL OBAMA,
F.B.I., DOJ, DEEP STATE
OFFICIALS
OFFICIAL
OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
IS A SEVERE CONSTITUTIONAL
ABUSE.
THEY'VE COMPLETELY SHREDDED THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND PEOPLE
COULD AND SHOULD END UP BEHIND
BARS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS THANKFULLY IS SAYING
TONIGHT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL BE INVESTIGATING
THESE FISA ABUSES.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MUST ADHERE TO THE HIGH
STANDARDS IN THE FISA COURT.
YES, IT WILL BE INVESTIGATED.
AND I THINK THAT'S JUST THE
APPROPRIATE THING.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL TAKE
THAT AS ONE OF THE MATTERS HE
WILL DEAL WITH
>> HANNITY: FINALLY, WE'VE BEEN
UNPEALING THIS STORY FOR OVER A
YEAR WHILE, OF COURSE, THE
LIBERAL MEDIA THEY'VE BEEN LYING
TO YOU, OBSESSING OVER SO-CALLED
THRUM OF-RUSSIA CONCLUSION,
WHICH IS NOTHING MORE THAN TO
THIS POINT A CONSPIRACY THEORY
THEY'VE CREATED OUT OF THIN AIR.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE.
BY THE WAY, AS FOR THE EXTENSIVE
UNPRECEDENTED OBAMA-ERA FISA
ABUSES, WE HAVE A MOUNTAIN OF
INCON TROW VERTABLE AND
CORROBORATED FACTS IN EVIDENCE.
ADAM SHIV'S COUNTER MEMO ON FISA
ABUSES HAS CONFIRMED EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN REPORTING ON,
AND EVERYTHING THAT IS ALSO IN
THE TWO REPUBLICAN MEMOS ON THE
SCANDAL.
THAT'S WHY THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDE
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDU
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDL
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDC
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDN
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDM
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDS
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDO
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSID
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDH
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDC
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDN
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDA
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSID.
THAT'S WHY THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
HAS BEEN IGNORING WHAT IS INSIDE
THE SCHIFF MEMO.
HERE'S EVERYTHING THAT THE
SCHIFF MEMO CORROBORATES FROM
THE NUNEZ AND GRAHAM MEMOS, THIS
COMPLETELY UNVERIFIED CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER THAT
USED RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES
MADE UP, IN FACT, A LARGE PART
OF THAT FISA APPLICATION TO
SURVEIL TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE
CARTER PAGE.
ADAM SCHIFF ACTUALLY WRITES THAT
A SECTION OF THE FISA
APPLICATION REFERENCES PARTS OF
THE PHONEY DOSSIER ABOUT CARTER
PAGE MEETING WITH RUSSIANS IN
MOSCOW IN JUNE OF 2016.
PAGE, BY THE WAY, IS TEE INTO
AING THESE LIES AND THAT THEY'VE
NEVER BEEN PROVEN TRUE.
I THINK MUELLER WOULD HAVE
ARRESTED HIM BY NOW OR AT LEAST
CHARGED HIM.
REMEMBER, THE GRASSLY AND GRAHAM
MADE UP THE BULK OF THIS FISA
APPLICATION.
NOW, SCHIFF DIDN'T SAY THAT,
BUT, YEAH, HE ADMITS THE DOSSIER
WAS USED, AND THE SCHIFF MEMO
ALSO CORROBORATES THAT, IN FACT,
THE F.B.I. AND THE DOJ LIED, AND
PURPOSELY AND MALICIOUSLY MISLED
A FISA JUDGE ABOUT CLINTON AND
THE DNC PAYING OVER $12 MILLION
FOR THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER OF
UNVERIFIED LIES AND PROPAGANDA.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS IS
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY?
NOW SCHIFF'S MEMO ACTUALLY
QUOTES PORT OF THE FISA
APPLICATION ABOUT THE DOSSIER
HAVING POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
THE APPLICATION NEVER BOTHERED
TO MENTION THAT IT WAS HILLARY
OR THE DNC THAT PAID FOR THAT
DOSSIER.
THE F.B.I. KNEW THIS, BUT THEY
PURPOSELY HID IT FROM THE FISA
JUDGE.
NOT RANK AND FILE F.B.I.
THE HIGHER ECHELON THAT WE TALK
ABOUT.
THEY USED IT TO GET A WARRANT TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
ANOTHER KEY POINT THAT THE
SCHIFF MEMO CONFIRMS.
THE FISA APPLICATION DID MENTION
A YAHOO NEWS ARTICLE ABOUT
MICHAEL ISIKOFF THAT HE WROTE
ABOUT CARTER PAGE.
SCHIFF HOWEVER LIED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THE JUDGE WAS NEVER
MADE AWARE THAT THE SOURCE FOR
THE YAHOO ARTICLE WAS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
NOW THE REPUBLICAN MEMO ACTUALLY
DEDAYS HOW THIS IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM BECAUSE THAT MEANS THE
INFORMATION WAS NEVER VERIFIED
BY TWO INDEPENDENT SOURCES SINCE
STEELE WAS THE ONLY SOURCE.
SO THOSE POINTS THAT THE SCHIFF
MEMO ACTUALLY CONFIRMS.
HERE ARE THE KEY FACT THAT THE
SCHIFF MEMO FLAT OUT LIES ABOUT.
THE CONGRESSMAN CLAIMS THAT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS NEVER SPIED
ON.
THAT IS A LIE 100% FALSE AND
HERE'S WHY.
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GRANTED A FISA WARRANT, THAT
GIVES THEM ACCESS TO EVERY ONE
OF CARTER PAGE'S OLD EMAILS, OLD
TEXT MESSAGES, AND THEY KNOW
EVERY PHONE CALL HE MADE WHICH
COULD DATE BACK TO WHEN HE WAS
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
NOW SCHIFF CLAIMS FORMER DEPUTY
F.B.I. DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE
THAT HE NEVER TESTIFIED THAT
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER THERE NEVER
WOULD HAVE BEEN A FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION.
BUT THE SCHIFF MEMO NEVER OFFERS
ANY PROOF, WHICH LIKELY MEANS IT
DOESN'T EXIST, AND MY SOURCES
CONFIRM THAT, IN FACT, MCCABE
SAID THAT.
AND SCHIFF DOES ADMIT THAT
STEELE WAS FIRED BY THE F.B.I.
FOR THESE MEDIA LEAKS.
BUT WHAT SCHIFF DOESN'T SAY IS
THAT STEELE LIED TO THE F.B.I.
ABOUT HIS MEDIA CONTACTS.
THE SCHIFF MEMO TRIES TO PLAY UP
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S CREDIBILITY
BY SAYING, WELL, HE'S WORKED
WITH THE F.B.I. IN THE PAST.
YEAH, THEY JUST FIRED HIM.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, SCHIFF NEVER
MENTIONED THAT STEELE WAS USING
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES, AND
THAT THE INFORMATION WAS NEVER
VERIFIED INDEPENDENTLY BY THE
F.B.I. OR THE DOJ OR BY ANYBODY.
SO IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
USED FOR ANY FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION AT ALL.
FINALLY SCHIFF OMITS THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF EVIDENCE,
ACCORDING TO OUR REPORTING, THE
DOSSIER PUT THE FISA APPLICATION
OVER THE TOP.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU THE FIRST TIME THEY
TRIED, IT FAILED.
THE FISA APPLICATION WAS DENIED.
THEN THE DOSSIER, WELL, THEY
ADDED THAT TO GET THE HELP THAT
WAS NEEDED SO THEY COULD "GET IT
APPROVED".
AND THEY LIED TO THE JUDGE.
WHAT IT MEANS IS WE HAVE THREE
CONGRESSIONAL MEMOS THAT PROVE A
KEY FACT.
THE F.B.I. LIED TO A FISA JUDGE
ABOUT THE CLINTON AND DNC
FINANCING THE DOSSIER, WHICH WAS
FILLED WITH UNCORROBORATED
RUSSIAN LIES, AND THEY DID IT TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF
SESSIONS, GLAD HE'S MOVING.
HE NEEDS TO MOVE QUICKLY.
EVERYBODY INVOLVED NEEDS TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
WE NEED TO RESOURCE THE RULE OF
LAW.
ALL RIGHT.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, WE HAVE
MORE NEWS ABOUT BROWARD COUNTY
AND THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
MISSING COUNTLESS WARNING SIGNS
ABOUT THE FLORIDA SCHOOL
SHOOTER, AND UTTERLY FAILING TO
PROPERLY RESPOND TO THIS DEADLY
RAMPAGE.
NOW THIS IS ONE HUGE, MASSIVE,
GIANT, BEAUROCRATIC FAILURE
AFTER ANOTHER IN THIS CASE.
AND BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF,
SCOTT ISRAEL IS FLAT OUT
REFUSING TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY.
INSTEAD HE'S BLAMING PRETTY MUCH
EVERYBODY ELSE.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THIS IS
ALMOST UNCON SHEENABLE, FOUR OF
SHERIFF ISRAEL'S DEPUTIES DID
NOT ENTER THE BUILDING WHILE THE
SHOOTING WAS HAPPENING.
ONE DEPUTY, A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER ON THE SCENE, SCOTT
PETERSON, WAS ARMED WITH A GUN
AND BULLET PROOF VEST.
HE TOOK UP A POSITION OUTSIDE
THE BUILDING WHILE THE SHOOTING
WAS TAKING PLACE.
ONE STUDENT DESCRIBED PETERSON
AS STANDING STILL AFTER HE HEARD
SHOT AFTER SHOT BEING FIRED.
PETERSON'S DEFENDING HIS ACTIONS
AND ENDED UP RESIGNING.
WHAT WE'RE NOW LEARNING IS THAT
THE FIRST MEMBER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ENTER THE SCHOOL,
THEY WERE ACTUALLY FROM THE
CORAL SPRINGS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THOSE OFFICERS RUSHED RIGHT IN.
BROWARD COUNTY DEPUTIES TOOK UP
A DEFENSIVE POSTURE AND POSITION
OUTSIDE.
ALSO NEW TONIGHT, FOX NEWS
REPORTING THAT BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ALSO
PREVENTED THE EMTS FROM ENTERING
THE SCHOOL.
AND THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT,
WELL, WOULD IT BE PROPER
PROTOCOL?
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS WERE SHOT
AND DYING AND BLEEDING.
SOURCES ARE TELLING OUR OWN
LAURA INGRAHAM THAT BROWARD
COUNTY SHERIFF DEPUTIES WERE
TOLD NOT TO GO INTO THE SCHOOL
UNLESS THEIR BODY CAMERAS WERE
TURNED ON, EVEN THOUGH THOSE
DEPUTIES APPARENTLY DIDN'T HAVE
THEM.
SARAH CARTER BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT, REPORTING UNDERSHERIFF
SCOTT ISRAEL'S LEADERSHIP,
APPARENTLY THERE HAVE BEEN 40
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THAT
DEPARTMENT OF MISCONDUCT.
WE DID REACH OUT TO THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE FOR COMMENT ON
SARAH'S STORY.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD BACK.
THIS IS ALL ONE, HUGE, MASSIVE,
GIANT BLUNDER AFTER ANOTHER
WHILE STUDENTS AND TEACHERS WERE
BEING SLAUGHTERED INSIDE THE
SCHOOL.
SADLY, THAT'S JUST PART OF THE
STORY.
THE F.B.I. WAS ALERTED NOT ONCE
BUT TWICE ABOUT NICHOLAS CRUZ
AND HIS SINSTER INTENTIONS
INCLUDING WEEKS BEFORE THE
MASSACRE.
ONE IDENTIFIED WOMAN TOLD
AUTHORITIES SHE FEARED CRUZ
WOULD, GET INTO A SCHOOL AND
SHOOT THE PLACE UP UNQUOTE.
THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE RECEIVED 18 SPECIFIC
WARNING CALLS ABOUT CRUZ SINCE
2008.
AND LAW ENFORCE MANY, IMAGINE
THIS, VISITED THIS KID'S HOME A
WHOPPING 39 TIMES IN A
SEVEN-YEAR PERIOD.
WE ALSO KNOW CRUZ RAISED ALL
KINDS OF RED FLAGS AT SCHOOL.
HE WASN'T ALLOWED TO WEAR A
BACKPACK BECAUSE OF SECURITY
CONCERNS, AND HE WAS ULTIMATELY
EXPELLED BECAUSE OF HIS
BEHAVIOR.
AND OF COURSE HE POSTED ALL
THESE DISTURBING IMAGES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
WARNING SIGNS MISSED AT EVERY
SINGLE LEVEL HERE.
NOW PEOPLE DID THE RIGHT THING.
THEY SAW SOMETHING, THEY SAID
SOMETHING, THEY ALERTED
AUTHORITIES.
THESE AUTHORITIES DROPPED THE
BALL ON A LEVEL I CAN'T EVEN
COMPREHEND.
THEY DIDN'T DO THEIR JOBS.
THEY FAILED THIS COMMUNITY IN
FLORIDA.
AND THESE OFFICIALS NEED TO BE
OWNING UP TO THEIR MISTAKES SO
IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN, AND WE
CAN FIX THE PROBLEMS IN THE
SYSTEM.
PREVENT A FUTURE MASSACRE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
YOU'VE HEARD PEOPLE LIKE BROWARD
COUNTY SHERIFF, SCOTT ISRAEL,
REFUSING TO OWN UP TO HIS
FAILURES.
HE WON'T ANSWER KEY QUESTIONS.
HE PATS HIMSELF ON THE BACK, AND
AS A GENERAL OVERALL LACK OF
SYMPATHY.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHEN DID YOU FIND OUT DEPUTY
PETERSON HAD NOT GONE INTO THE
BUILDING?
HOW SOON AFTER THE SHOOTING DID
YOU KNOW THAT?
>> NOT FOR DAYS.
>> HOW MANY DAYS?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
>> YOU DIDN'T LOOK AT THE VIDEO?
ONE WEEK AFTER THE SHOOTING, YOU
HADN'T LOOKED AT THE VIDEO YET?
>> I LOOKED AT THE VIDEO AS SOON
AS OUR INVESTIGATORS -- IT
WASN'T MY JOB TO LOOK AT THE
VIDEO.
IT WAS THE INVESTIGATORS JOB TO
LOOK AT THE VIDEO.
>> THE FAMILIES WERE AT THE
SCENE IN TOWN HALL, AND YOU
COULD HAVE DISCLOSED TO THEM.
>> I COULDN'T DISCLOSE IT THEN
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
CORROBORATION.
I COULD ONLY TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR WHAT I KNEW ABOUT.
I EXERCISED MY DUE DILIGENCE.
I'VE GIVEN AMAZING LEADERSHIP TO
THIS AGENCY.
>> AMAZING LEADERSHIP OR WILL
YOU RESIGN?
>> OF COURSE I WON'T RESIGN.
>> DO YOU THINK IF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF'S OFFICE HAD DONE THINGS
DIFFERENTLY, THIS SHOOTING MIGHT
NOT HAVE HAPPENED?
>> LISTEN, IF IT'S BEEN BLESSED
WITH CANDY AND NUTS, O.J.
SIMPSON WOULD STILL BE IN THE
RECORD BOOKS.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THE SHERIFF IS IN
DENIAL, OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY.
WHICH IS WHY PEOPLE ARE CALLING
ON HIM TO NOW RESIGN.
INSTEAD OF DOING EVERYTHING WE
JUST SHOWED, YOU SHERIFF ISRAEL
SHOULD BE APOLOGIZING TO THE
VICTIM'S FAMILIES AND CORRECTING
THE ISSUES THAT DIDN'T STOP THIS
MASS SHOOTING.
AND HIS DEPUTIES GOING INTO THAT
BUILDING.
SHERIFF ISRAEL DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE INTERESTED IN DOING ANY OF
THIS.
LAST WEEK HE SAID THAT HE MIGHT
NOT EVEN RELEASE THE FOOTAGE
SHOWING DEPUTY SCOTT PETERSON
FAILING TO ENTER THE BUILDING.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAYS.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO DISCLOSE
THE VIDEO AT THIS TIME, AND WE
MAY NEVER DISCLOSE THE VIDEO,
DEPENDING ON THE PROSECUTION AND
THE CRIMINAL CASE.
BUT WHAT I SAW WAS A DEPUTY
ARRIVE AT THE WEST SIDE OF
BUILDING 12, TAKE UP A POSITION,
AND HE NEVER WENT IN.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
WHATEVER FOOTAGE THE SHERIFF HAS
SHOULD BE RELEASED TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, ALL OF YOU,
AND THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA AND
THESE FAMILIES DESERVE TO SEE IT
IF THEY WANT TO SEE IT.
SHERIFF ISRAEL NEEDS TO STOP